this was a it was a gloomy Outlook from
anje Duda it was a significant interview
because he seems to have shifted
slightly on the issue particularly of of
fighter jets and the way Ukraine is
armed Duda is an important man he's uh
one of the leading countries pushing for
harder supports and and harder
intervention uh with uh Ukraine and he's
the man at the moment in the sense that
next week as we look ahead to the
anniversary of the invasion of Ukraine
he will be hosting Joe Biden and a
number of allies in Poland for events
commemorating marking that anniversary
and trying to work out what to do uh
next uh he's always though kind of towed
the line the NATO line when it came to
fighter jets although he's pushed four
more robust arming of Ukraine in
different ways he's always said this
decision on fighter jets modern fighter
jets needs to be made across the NATO
alliance by consensus but I think in
this interview he was more forthright uh
than that he said after meeting with
President zielinski
um he has come to the conclusion that
not only does Ukraine long-range
artillery does it need more air defenses
and more modern battle tanks but
eventually he says in the future it will
need fighter jets too
um foreign
there seems a lot of concern at the
moment over Munitions whether the West
is producing enough shells for the
ukrainians to fight the Russians are
getting through so many but also whether
these modern battle tanks at the West
has agonized over sending whether
they're going to get there in time for
this counter-offensive how worried are
you that there's just not going to be
the time to get these crucial weapons to
the ukrainians to see off that Russian
threat
is technology
um
foreign
and Carnage and annihilation in Ukraine
do you think the worst is over is that
is the coming year going to be any
better
a
so you think the ball might be over
within a year do you think
um
[Music]
foreign
very important week in terms of how NATO
is dealing with Russia his warning is
really that uh Putin is trying to
exhaust the west and if it's if he
succeeds he's not going to stop with
Ukraine this conflict could widen and
deepen and he may well attack another
country uh in the in the mind at least
said the warnings evangela his main
point is that the West can give all it
wants to Ukraine but Russia has one big
advantage that Ukraine can never have
and that is it doesn't care about its
men it is prepared to send thousands of
them into this war against Ukraine and
doesn't really care how they uh whether
they live or die and it's that use of
mass of quantity against quality that is
the Big Challenge and therefore that's
the reason why the President says that
the West needs to give more even more to
Ukraine if it's going to see off this
threat from Russia